[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle pour nos
chances
il va falloir je me rase as le nez oui
donc c'est pas vous qui décidez si je
sais d'accord moi c'est parce que vous
parlez très très bon jeu
je sais que ça représentait le voltage
excusez moi vous êtes à fond là en
volume oui
qu'est ce que vous regardez là
non c'est votre barbe il me disait vous
n'êtes pas rasé depuis nikita en fait
pour la cérémonie vous avez des idées
marrante pansements way
succéder dilma rente regardez par
exemple ça c'est quoi
il meurt signé qui fait des pompes son
âme et loire
mais rld me connaissait
bonne chance
chez kim dit tout le temps de sourire de
faire bonne figure
en fait il dit que j'ai une mission dans
la vie maîtres du rire et de la joie
dans la cérémonie des césar a des
chances
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir mais là c'est là paraît qu'elle
est aux prédateurs producteurs dans la
salle il a suivi les consignes et les
gros bras
oui pareil contre 2 proposait deux faces
mais aussi de profil
ça peut toujours servir
[Musique]
que c'est beau c'est johan marie paule
châtain et me voilà non
tu es
nous savions
oui là je dis ça
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une dernière petite rockette oui quand
vous m'appellerez sur scène pour être
présenté sous le nom de joker non
florence foresti
pourquoi jean-pierre bon reconnaissez
pas là j'ai la gueule du jockey florence
foresti [ __ ] la gomme barbie points
mais les poussettes et compliquent a
plié joker sort d'où je suis là
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs votre maîtresse de
cérémonie
florence foresti
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
monde
[Musique]
espérons que ce conflit
ça va
goulon je suis
m
[Musique]
comment
m
trop
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]